now on this mother or father ever I was
full of expectations when I started
working for a big company in 2010 but
what awaited me there was an absolute
culture shock had absolutely clue to a
shock today's Chevy boycott gives talks
based on her experience as a
representative of Generation Y those now
between 20 and 30 years old and vammas
movie Generation Y is more about having
a modern attitude something both young
and old people can have Conan after two
years of working for a chemical company
she realized that she just didn't fit in
there doesn't everyone take a gun we
were all going down the stairs and I was
first in line the others were behind me
like ducks in a row suddenly my boss
said from behind me Pablo cut please use
the hand rail I turned around and saw
that everyone was using the hand rail
and thought okay they're playing a joke
on me so I laughed but no one else did
so I thought hmm ok I'll use the hand
rail too ok as a penalty he thought in
hand love her work day was completely
structured Burkhart couldn't stand just
going through the motions and quit today
she works as a coach at a small
consulting firm in Cologne it has just
eight employees and a flat hierarchy the
29 year old decides for herself when her
day begins sometimes she works at the
office other times at home flexibility
is the key design we wouldn't get
outside and aims to I'd like to connect
work and leisure because it results in a
new perspective a new view of work and
maybe to the notion of performance team
a license for us performance is not
about do it do it do it for 12 hours and
then my free time starts and with it the
fun instead the fun is linked to the
work slean's ons on them father said I
said yo who da bed for boonton doing the
same things every day following set
procedures punching a time clock
generation y is calling all that into
question for these young people free
time is more important than climbing the
career ladder
these digital natives who've grown up
with smart phones and the Internet are
used to working anytime anywhere so
youth researcher Klaus harlmann says
companies need to accommodate their
wishes especially when skilled workers
are in short supply Alice does your name
forbids it all advances the company most
of it is in the management books it
abolish rigid hierarchies make work
processes flow let employees participate
and help shape things and you'll achieve
much higher productivity did via Noctis
who does that automatically and to meet
their own needs the younger generation
he only be natural boar card is leading
a workshop for managers she designed the
program herself it's about developing a
modern management style the participants
belonged to an older generation that's
why I'm annoyed analyzing other people
function differently was new for me I'm
always telling my kids work first then
play and they don't like that so it's
good to see things through other eyes
and adapt accordingly conflictive Lee
doesn't know I wouldn't call it a
conflict it's a completely normal debate
things change in life and baby putting
more emphasis on free time is not such a
bad thing mirror the Beast become a
socialite okari's asleep Generation Y is
often accused of lacking ambition and
being very self-centered if you had any
sanghas money at sunken gardens wouldn't
you say that the younger generation is
an egotistical generation yes
individualism is increasing and the
desire for freedom and self-fulfillment
is growing but on the other hand we're
also the generation that wants to work
with others annonces on which is used to
working in teams and networking team
zissou ottoman teams to alva and see
Stefan Edson Steffi boycott hopes to put
her generation in a different light and
audience appears to be very receptive to
her message